hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
according to the NSA documents i'm dave
rubin I've got kira soltanovich David
Nussbaum with me and we are going to
jump right into it okay the government
they are listening to your phone calls
their data mining your internet they
could be watching this right now which
would be very disturbing and a new study
came out this week Americans are idiots
basically and don't mind that the
government is is watching you and
listening to you and tracking you let's
take a look at some numbers okay privacy
verse security fifty six percent of
Americans considered it acceptable for
the NSA to get secret court orders to
track calls of millions of Americans to
investigate terrorism sixty-two percent
say it's more important for the federal
government to investigate possible
terror threats even that even if that
intrudes on our personal privacy
sixty-nine percent of Democrats and
sixty-two percent of republicans say
it's more important for the government
to investigate terrorist threats even at
the expense of personal privacy this
seems completely insane to me because if
we don't have our privacy what do we
have our Americans have we just given up
like is the government is it all over it
is the freedom of America and all that
stuff just out the window Kyra as a
Soviet former USSR i immigrated to this
country you know time like the
Communists like must get moose and
squirrel remember wait really you were
born I was born there I'm totally cool
with it it's like finally America you
guys are on board to the old Soviet ways
yeah and I'm cool the government wants
to check in on my facebook if Obama
likes a couple of my pictures you know
what I mean i'll be happy with this so
this is cool by me but isn't that why
your family probably left the USSR
because yes but you know it worked it
worked back then where people were
scared people were you know you know
sitting up straight hands in their laps
fallen directions and i think that's
what this country needs it was a simpler
life sort of like you know we have one
toilet paper in Russia
that is it yeah Yakov Smirnoff you don't
get a yacht that was yakone yeah was in
Russia toilet paper what do you think I
mean that those numbers seem crazy to me
that Americans are so willing to just
give up their privacy I've been spied on
my whole life you know I lived with my
parents until I was in my 20s and said
hey they made me keep the door unlocked
they would spy on me in the middle then
makes a smoke a lot of pot yeah they
wanted to make sure that I was always a
you know big brother was always watching
me yeah so um this isn't anything new
for me I've started writing more in my
diary so that's offline and I think then
I think everything will be fine yeah
yeah I blocked my mom on facebook so I
did and how did you have that
conversation because I would love oh she
does get rid of she doesn't know she
doesn't know she loves Facebook and so
you know she's all over that stuff but
she doesn't have some I blocks you know
if you post a picture on her thing you
know but as far as the NSA um yeah I'm I
don't really like being spied on but if
there's really not much I can do i'll
just take it offline i'm not on facebook
anyway but we all know that we've been
spied on for years right this isn't new
so we just assumed it all these years
cuz right like this doesn't seem that
shocking to me that they've been going
through our emails i mean gmail
basically tells you that right right i
googled my way to get here right i don't
even know if i'm using that verbiage
correctly but like I whatever I math
question my way to get here yeah and it
said you can we will you allow us to
basically track where you're going uh
yeah cuz I want to get there yes yes you
can see you can watch me if that's what
gets your rocks off you can watch me get
to where I'm going to the Rubin report
yeah but I automatically click on that
some sort of big open space that they
can just pull all the information about
everything yeah I'm doing in that moment
I have exams I'm surprised that I have
two comedians here who are so cool with
privacy sort of disappearing because you
know there there's gotta be emails you
guys have sent that you would not that
you're doing anything illegal
necessarily but that you don't want to
be you know you get some rogue agent at
the NSA blackmailing you okay no matter
the emails I send are all illegal good
texts are illegal yeah yeah I mean they
don't don't don't spy on me anymore than
you would normally spy on me but it's
probably something really hardcore going
on yeah I think that what's going to
happen is and I think this is actually
good yeah because when something like
this opens up the floodgates and all of
a sudden everybody knows what's going on
now people can start making better
choices because there are certain apps
that i will not download on my phone
because i will read not always but once
in a while I'll read the agreement and
one of the apps i wanted to do my camera
for what it was but it was basically
allowing you to make free phone calls
all right absolutely sign me up and then
i read a little like hey by the way that
means we get to fist any pets you have a
minute that's it when i read the fine
print and so they would have access to
my entire phone basically right so you
know what I didn't download that up so
now everybody will be more aware and
maybe this wool maybe this will start
some sort of little mini revolution with
smartphones and with the way we use our
email that will start saying no yeah no
apps better figure out a new way to rob
and steal from us and figure out what we
buy what kind of chips I like right
because I don't want you to have access
to you know my dad's pin code right
which by the way I don't have so please
don't go after right and you're the rare
case of someone that actually read that
that 30 page thing that you just can
click one button like people are really
like oh yeah itunes I'm gonna read this
whole thing yeah the way down click
accept and I just what just worry about
it later everybody else is doing it
exactly that's how David dates also he
just scrolled finger down to what the
chick says and it goes fine yes I'll buy
it for you whatever you want what do you
guys think of Edward Snowden the guy who
is the whistleblower the leaker because
people are saying is your hero or is he
a traitor because you can only be one of
two things in America you know to be
fine there's no room for nuance or maybe
he's a little of something both but I've
seen a lot of people like Peter King
he's a congressman in New York saying
you know we what we should try him under
the Espionage Act because he's released
so many state secrets and people are
gonna be under the threat of terror
ambala that that seems kind of crazy to
me this all seems good they
basically what do you guys think about
him I think he's gonna be judged by
America once he's on Dancing with the
Stars and then we can all chime in and
tell tell him what we really think about
him yeah I I don't think he's a hero and
I also don't think he should be tried
under espionage that seems a little
ridiculous yeah I think he's smart to go
to Hong Kong because if you're gonna be
stuck if you're gonna be snowed in
somewhere right am i right and there's
mongolian chicken that can't be a bad
thing yeah do they have the same kind of
food we have no we go yeah I'm sure
there's I thought was there yeah they
might but and that's a smart place i
would go to talk to hong kong hello in
batman in the second Batman remember
Batman went all the way to hong kong to
get that guy remember him bring him back
for trial and Gotham so it's not like we
can't get this guy that's true is that
why you think he went because he's
waiting for Batman to pick him up I
think maybe that is it it's possible
that's genius yeah is it art imitating
life imitating art imitating life it's a
lot of ass tibitius circle it really is
what do you think hero or traitor no I
don't have an opinion either way as far
as a hero or villain but or traitor I'm
a little concerned why he would do
something like this he's got this hot
pole dancer girlfriend they're living in
Hawaii they're enjoying their lifestyle
he's making 107,000 dollars a year I
think leave well enough alone bang
you're beautiful stripper girlfriend and
and you know why why throw caution to
the wind yeah I do that see that's I
have an opinion on I think you're a
dummy for doing that right yeah right he
gave up a pretty cushy life in in Hawaii
with a stripper although why was he so
pale in Hawaii why would anyone that's
live that's the weird thing to me like I
know he's another guy but why are you so
pays actually tan for an albino yeah
that is actually tan yeah yeah great
skin tone for someone from Russia well
this is a picture russian people are a
little redder means well you're rattan
you look like you could be from Morocco
I'm a Soviet jus so I have that dark
menacing jus look ah yeah yeah that's
what that very menacing Mary yeah I
might be a young turk actually my last
name is soltanovich the Sultan's are for
so you know saying sir yeah yeah well we
did turkey last weekend we're gonna let
CNN handle turkey because they're so
good they're so good do all right let's
move on uh Hillary Clinton have you
heard of this lady she just joined her I
guess she was on Twitter but she has
activated her Twitter account she also
got verified with in like an hour which
took me I don't tell you what I did to
get it anyway she is on Twitter let's
look at her bio and break it down for
you at Hillary Clinton wife mom lawyer
women & kids advocate floor which one
what is that what does that stand for
arkansas AR Kait guy thank you FLOTUS
First Lady of the United States US
Senator Secretary of State author dog
owner hair icon pantsuit aficionado
glass ceiling cracker TBD and I think
we're gonna start with the TBD thing
because that's what everybody's talking
about is hilly is it already preordained
is Hillary Clinton the next president of
the United States David oh no Hillary
Clinton is not the next president of the
United States why what everybody's no no
no black no I'm pretty sure it's going
to be a former governor of Minnesota
Jesse Ventura hello you're going to
crazy ah he's got a conspiracy theory
for everything he won't let this NSA you
know when you know happened yeah he'll
make sure that nothing crazy goes
undetected Howard Stern will be his vice
president he literally said that he
wants yeah that he wants to run and have
her ticket I I run III go with that
ticket I reversing Stern and inventor no
not a good idea like a California
gubernatorial race remember we just we
had what you talking about Willis with
Gary Coleman running and n words the
porn star that's just insane yeah
Hillary what do you think you know um I
thought TVD meant the best dancer I'm so
confused and I seen her break it down a
bit and pop lock have you seen her
Harlem shake bill has an office up in
Harlem don't think she hasn't done a
little bit of shaken up second see her
twerking
that big booty ah young she drops it
like it's very lukewarm you know I I say
why not I think she absolutely could run
yeah absolutely but she has to clear up
this Benghazi scandal first hey this
isn't Fox man it's ridiculous enough
enough I so as far as why not it seems
to me that like I've said this on the
show before but you know we left England
a long time ago because we didn't want
you know like one or two families
running everything all the time and if
we were to go from Clinton then we had a
couple bushes back to Clinton back to
Bush back to Clinton and there's already
another bush you know George P bush
who's part latino and good looking so
they're very excited about him for like
20 20 it's like don't we need to escape
having these families that just run the
show yes another bush would be awful
because the first two they didn't have a
great track record right but under
Clinton we had we had we had good times
so you're willing we had a good time so
I would say hey okay let's go with that
again although I think it would be a
completely different administration it's
a completely different country that was
20 years ago you know we would I don't
think it would be the same Clinton yeah
and it's a woman you know I think it
would be completely different whereas
George senior george w George Latino you
know I mean it would be kind of the same
thing just a different palette of it
yeah I've been the same color scheme of
mood so I would not be for that yeah
well I am with you at least that the
Clintons deserve a little more credit
certainly the bushes what do you think
this idea that we they all have to be
celebrities because Hillary is basically
a celebrity at this point more than a
politician I'm just looking forward to
the Saturday Night Live sketches that
will come out of all this I mean another
bush yeah or another Clinton yeah in in
office uh for me yeah does the president
even really run the country so I think
you need to have a good looking
celebrity to run things to at least be
the face of the country and then have a
team of writers that actually you know
manipulate what happened right well I
don't know if the President on things
cuz you know Obama said that you know
the buck
stops with me which every president says
but they're all this stuff keeps coming
up with the NSA and IRS Ababwa and it's
always well low-level employees are
running the whole thing he's the
president how could that you know get to
him well looks the IRS nothing to do
with Obama right do you don't think he
was sitting in an office really highly
doubt it right the IRS scandal that
they're trying to make it seem like is
because these these folks these find
that happen to be tea party you know
corporations we're not doing that their
due diligence on the paperwork that they
filled out all right if you're going to
get money and you're going to you're
going to go start doing political stuff
with it and not help the community which
is what they were filing under you're
going to get red-flagged that's all it
is so that nothing to do with the aisle
are saying it's a red flag when an
organization that says they don't want
to pay taxes is actually looked at right
it seems yeah yeah it's all this stuff
all these scammers are coming up for
Obama have really nothing to do with
Obama yeah I mean they really don't they
are just under his administration so it
makes them look bad but back to the
Hillary thing really quickly if if we
had a Hillary president right let's say
for eight years whatever and then
Chelsea you want it to run then I'd be
like you guys give someone else a turn
like I have a two-year-old right and
we're always like share you don't mean
like you had your turn now let's share
let's share the country with other
wealthy families yeah do you think maybe
we need a little bit of what most of the
world has or at least Europe where they
have either royalty or they have a
president who's sort of ceremonial and
then a prime minister like we're trying
to get it all out in one guy which i
think is part of the problem like we
can't expect Obama to actually govern
and be the biggest superstar on the
planet what do you think split it up
into a president who's just like the
party guy and the prime minister who you
know does the work I still can't get
over the fact that Hillary's got 400,000
Twitter followers and learn one day I
know I mean I've been on for four years
I haven't even cracked 20,000 yet it's
the Clinton name that's the point yeah
you need to change it is a royal name
yeah yeah it is a retainer you you
almost want you root
oil all right you guys aren't going to
believe this but George W Bush we were
just talking about people dig him
impossible yeah a new gallup poll has
come out and for the first time since
2005 more Americans have a favorable
view of gwb than an unfavorable view
forty-nine percent have a positive
opinion of them and forty-six percent
have a negative opinion of him this just
because of scandal Palooza that like
everyone's like feeling a little tired
of Obama for the first time so maybe
over kind of missing George W Bush a
little bit baby brink um you know when
you break up with a girl years go by and
then you start to remember them fondly
yeah ember the time they keyed your car
or they or they started checking all of
your voicemail or invaded the wrong
country exactly happen some dress in
relationships and I think that's what's
happening here people are starting to
remember like the good things you know
the goofy things about george w bush the
fact that he could like go out and throw
out a first pitch and it would be a
strike like obama is not good at that
kind of stuff well we think fondly you
know bush could bowl and that you know
and you gave us some great moments the
whole fool me once I I don't know just
that don't just don't fool me and yeah
yeah yeah I think people like that kind
of stuff we need another goofy president
what do you think I want to see these
polls I would really love to see these
polls um are they saying they have fond
memories because he's not an office
anymore well that's where I contest of
these polls right I don't know that they
look back on the presidency any better
but this does sort of happen like people
always hate the president when their
president they're always embroiled in
scandals and whatever but then they get
out and people were like oh I he was
kind of he's on his ranch and he's not
bothering anybody yeah i mean i agree
with david's analogy you know i have
some douchey ex-boyfriends then I'm like
yeah he cheated on me but ah boys will
be boys right he just kind of like aa
presents with presidents it happens yeah
if this was because your act as a part
of you that's like look I'm not with
that president anymore so sure
he's okay yeah I really don't think
people are thinking on remember when
bush was president right man it was so
wonderful to be in the lowest economic
times of our lives all drats why
couldn't be back no no one's thinking
they want to be back there in that point
true I I do kind of think though this
has a little bit to do with that Bush
never I can't believe I'm gonna defend
George over here and i can and then the
comment section you guys go nuts if you
want um that partly it's because we
don't have any video of him like
outright consistently contradicting
himself you know even forget the iraq
war there was not a lot of video of him
contradicting himself you know but obama
now like everything that he said during
the campaign now they're showing that
like you know this NSA thing is the
perfect example like everything that
they're doing is exactly the reverse so
as part of this just because of media
and YouTube and video and twitter that
like now we can like call them out in a
way that we couldn't before i think most
people are stupid that live in this
country i think that's really the ones
watching yeah that's why I'm very we
have a smart but but honestly i-i didn't
vote for bush that's it I don't know I
have yeah so you can't take credit nor
fault at this poll I'm not exactly sure
why people are remembering him fondly
it's a it's a it's a bit confusing thing
I mean he's got that the for one of the
most illiterate presidents he's got this
librarian yeah yeah well everyone gets
the library you don't have to be
literate to get the lab but I'm saying
he's got this library which is he should
have like a maybe a circus or a or a
carnival named after him instead of
alana frozen yogurt stands yeah that
doors dummy most presidential froyo yeah
I I really do think it is because
everything is just piled on Obama at
once yeah and there's a ticking clock
now okay now it's your second term right
now you gotta get done what you said you
were gonna get done and he just keeps
getting cock-blocked by all these
different things that are just popping
up the drones and the IRS and the the AP
and
everything at once so yeah then all of a
sudden I was like let's take a poll now
and see their mission miss bush well
sure you'll be like well gee Bush never
had drones I liked him right no you
didn't yeah even the people that liked
Bush did not like bush yeah I think you
guys are both hitting on this but do you
also think it's partly just because of
our general short attention span that we
all now have like nobody remembers
anything anymore and the news cycle is
so quick and because of Twitter
everything is so quick that you just
forget things that you knew to be facts
everyone's fine and nothing is tangible
anymore really because before I remember
like we would have a newspaper we'd have
a newspaper in our house and you can go
and you could read an article if I see
something online I want to find it again
it's either been like you know swapped
out for whatever's new you know you go
to like the Yahoo front page but you
don't know whatever it's like where's
that thing I read it's like new
information all the time well that's
that was ten seconds ago yeah it's sort
of like the BuzzFeed ification of
America like we don't even read articles
we read pictures with like a little
caption in the form of an article right
right everything in our in our media is
Us Weekly yeah we're we're just passing
through it it's just like looking at the
pictures of Kim Kardashian's pregnant
yeah I have a complete ban on kardashian
show don't tweet a batter don't talk to
it okay thank you for letting me know
can we retract that anti Kardashian huh
completely auntie Kardashian all right
let's move on let's talk about Tim Tebow
mr. Jesus mr. football he signed with
the New England Patriots this week
people thought he was gonna be out of
the NFL altogether but he has come back
like Jesus kind of and and already I
look I was going crazy on twitter with
the jokes there is an endless amount of
this every comedian was doing it
basically so there's a couple ways I
want to go with this i want to start
sort of what what's the general thing
with religion and sports like why is it
so easy to make fun of this guy because
he can't throw the ball and he's a
quarterback right purely at a sports
level that a sports level yeah and and
then yeah he became like this worldwide
sensation practically like a character
caricature of himself with that whole
team
owing thing yeah which I don't even know
if he realizes what he was doing at
first but like yeah he's doing this
whole pray thing on the field because
God is paying attention to everything
that he does God love God and and
everybody at the you know I read an
article that said that twenty-five
percent of Americans really believed
that God had a UH had a hand in who wins
the Super Bowl I mean that's pretty
outraged these are the same people that
voted for Bush right in the last second
uh right so let's focus on that then
because this idea these guys they train
they practice you know 15 18 hours a day
they are the the world's peak athletes
and then some of them Tebow would be the
prime example thank God for everything
which seems so crazy because it's you
doing the work to be better and
accomplish things where it's like
cognitive dissidence kinda I don't I
would love to see the first Muslim
football player roll out of carpet Neil
to every time he makes a touchdown yeah
I would love to see what ninety-nine
percent of Americans will probably like
there's no place for religion in
football you take that our Aurora that's
not a place to do that really right I
would love for one of our people to Hava
Nagila every time I got a Grand Slam get
on a chair haha all of America they can
lift the base nickel if my base and you
know I mean get like a white
handkerchief haha we did it people would
be outraged up but Tim Tebow kneels down
and does a thing and praise and has like
Leviticus and both you know like Old
Testament New Testament under his eyes
and it's beautiful and it's wonderful
and it's inspirational right I mean look
I don't care honestly I don't care but I
don't think people realize how
hypocritical they are when you're not
Christian or Catholic or whatever and
that that's cool to me but it's like a
little show right it doesn't mean
anything to me it kind of takes up time
they give penalties to football players
who do like a dance in the end zone but
he's has a set up a whole manger scene
with like frankincense and myrrh diaz
three wise men come in every time he
makes a pass but that's okay I just feel
like it's really hypocritical yeah well
playing the devil's advocate for just
the second so it seems to me though that
we can make fun of him because he's
Christian so if there was a Muslim
player I would venture to say that all
the comedians on Twitter that are making
fun of tebow would not be nearly as as
offensive or as forward with the jokes
as they are with Tebow so does that go
to something about how we view
Christianity we we live in a Christian
society if Muslim or whatever religion
was the predominant religion I think you
can make fun of it because more people
are that right um but I think at this
point I don't even know Tebow really
believes or not in God or Jesus he's
like thank God thank God I believe you
know in God so much that I'm now on a
team again if it wasn't for religion he
wouldn't be on a team he maybe he's the
waterboy he runs a really fast you know
they have him clocked it like you know
for second milers writing some point so
that's interesting so you think it's
because of religion that he'd now got
picked up like if he had just this skill
set and wasn't this this Jesus Freak you
think he wouldn't have been picked up
well he's not that talented just think
it was a miracle that is a true it's
yeah yeah it's a modern day miracle
that's interesting cuz you know people
are saying Jason Collins the the
basketball player who came out who's
unsigned at the moment but a lot of
people are saying well he's gonna get
the benefit now where the NBA is gonna
be like somebody's gotta sign him you
know they're gonna force him into be
excited so maybe believing in God and
being gay can both help you in sports
does that make any sense that why I
can't throw is that my prostate it is
yes well I'm not an atheist yeah i'm
just not a shove it down your face
religious person right you know i'm like
a card holding Jew but it doesn't mean
anything really right in this world and
you're right it's we live in a
Christians America that I'd really them
you are right about a lot of things that
tie and that beard or two of them right
there but but it's always I think the
reason we can make fun of it is because
it's everywhere I mean it's in every
department store during Christmas and
Easter and I'll you know and all the
holiday type of things that you
like just basically just give in to it's
part of if you're American you are
celebrating this right if you're told
you have to have a Santa on your roof so
that's why I think comedians and people
can make fun of it and not feel like
someone's going to come after them
because it's kind of just what are our
country is about right and I think if he
is okay with what he's doing and he's
like look this is what I believe in and
this is what I i pray all the time
that's great but you have to realize you
kind of sort of look a little bit
ridiculous so just if you're
acknowledging it later I know I'm taking
up time to pray and do a whole thing and
um I still stand by i want to see a jew
do hava nagila after they score a
touchdown or you know the score a
touchdown and you made a basket a
basketball so clearly scored it like
this that's even better religion and I
just Sports expert kira soltanovich
right there all right let's move on we
gotta talk facebook because it seems
that the world has had it with Facebook
people are over it and I've seen this
coming for quite some time people are
not happy with their new app you know
they came out with the with the facebook
phone people don't like that usership
crendon downwards and then of course
this whole thing where they were going
to take over the search business from
from google and bing and all that that
has just fallen flat they do have one
point 1 billion users but more and more
people as i said are just not into it
people don't care whose birthday it is
they're not sharing stuff like they used
to and liking stuff like they used to so
is this just like because it became so
freakin corporate is that like the main
thing going on here it just became this
giant business we're at first it was
like this little fun thing and now it
just feels like this endless machine was
fun it was fun at first because it was
just it was a college thing right it was
like being a little a crew you know you
had your own little fun thing but yeah I
think it stopped being fun when my mom
don't yeah yeah this really is about
your mom you brought it up earlier and
again yeah mom get out of my head
no like I've moved on I've moved on to
to twitter twitter is the place to be a
vine is the new hotness right yeah 6
second ah did I say new hotness is that
1000 that was that was a fire i don't
like another thing to join I can't keep
up for comedians for for entertainers
that's a great thing you work out
material six second increments right
it's become very obvious to me since
I've been doing the show that comedians
love the one-way communication we love
Twitter cuz we're just putting it out
all the time and you and vine and all
that but Facebook it's like I actually
deleted my facebook page i have a fan
page and that's fine i post one thing a
day but i couldn't deal with all the
narcissistic just have a fan page no not
a friend originally there was it harder
getting all of your friends to become uh
I've lost some friends yeah I bet your
job but what do you I mean it seems to
me facebook is on the way out like it I
think it actually started with the movie
too because the movie to me like made it
you know the social network it made it
seem so dirty right how the whole thing
was created yeah that I just had this
taste in my mouth after like I just
don't like anything about this what any
time you look behind and you see the
great powerful oz is just this little
old man going don't ya the curtain then
I think people are just disenchanted
right away yeah like oh that's what it
is oh alright and my dad's on it yeah
you know my parents are on it and I do
have to watch what i post because I
don't want to look I have a grown woman
I have a mortgage I have a child I'm
still concerned about my parents think
about me and they cyber stalk me like
know they're watching this right now I
guarantee it not because I told them but
because what they do see on door thing
but they're like the slowest cyber
stalkers like they'll watch like a week
later but like I saw you today you did
the thing now that was a week ago but
good luck thanks for playing that is
true you know actually come to think of
it my dad every now and again will call
me like a week after I tweeted something
about are you sure you think that about
look I got a hundred retweet I don't
care if I if I really mean it I got the
the you know the reasons that I wanted
um I think it's here to stay though
don't you think it's gonna stay you
don't think it's going the way of my
space like that it'll just eventually
crumble and then something else in other
places something else will place it but
it'll it'll stick around it will stay it
will be like the phone book for a very
long time I still get the phone book
delivered to my house what do you do
with it it's just a prop up a kid when
you have a kid over to stop that's or is
everybody idea actually I mean what else
would one do with the phone book you
actually open a phone book and go well
I'm gonna look for a plumber I mean
would I just start reading it and you
treat people and say this is what you
get for still having your number in a
phone book but I don't we'll just it'll
be there it'll be there Facebook will
not go away easily yeah it will still be
around but we will move on let me say if
you guys could do just a digital reset
if you could just press a button one
time and just clear out the whole
freaking thing and start over would you
do it um no I wouldn't do it we mean
with everything the whole thing if you
just the whole bag that kind of sounds
whoa did you know like your mass suicide
rate I am talking about we are gonna
have koolaid passed out shortly and
we're going down know if you could just
press a button and reset the whole thing
so that all your all your digital
footprint whatever that is your your
Twitter your Facebook the whole thing
could just reset and you could start a
new my life would be completely
different I get into so much trouble in
my old relationship in my current
relationship always in trouble for being
on the phone but it's really well it's
candy crush saga now I think more than
anything else I haven't played it but
people are going by I do I've go bonkers
for i can't believe i just submitted
that cut this out you're not this part
no no it's dang it's um i did i did a
tweet which I thought was very funny it
makes fun of a disease muscle atrophy
right on Twitter I really need it on fun
but it's funny on Twitter right as i
wrote a first person to lose all their
muscle mass wins a trophy a trophy you
know it's funny when you read it i put
that on facebook and three people that i
went to high school with have kids with
muscle atrophy well you shouldn't
right that and I don't know it's a joke
i look at my timeline everything I write
is nonsense so that's why Facebook for
me yeah is really just a place for me to
look at baby pictures so maybe that's
part of time that Facebook has become
this like personal thing versus twitter
is like just this open i used to have my
twitter connected to my facebook yeah
right what couldn't even happy about no
yeah immediately I took I realized what
am i doing these are different people it
is like like you said your high school
friends it's like those friends that you
have and then you go off to summer camp
and it's those friends yeah you know I
know like twitter is like those bad
friend and they get you on a different
level and you can't mix the two you just
can't mean sometimes yes there is
overlap but hardly anyone on my facebook
is also on my Twitter yeah alright
commenter is a camera soltanovich and
get to it and we'll make sure we forward
everything over to her personally okay
last topic so subway the restaurant is
it a restaurant I don't know what it is
that place where they have some food and
the foot long and the six-inch and all
thing they you know they've been pushing
themselves as this healthy alternative
they took that fat slob Jared and turns
him just into like an average bum but
now it turns out that their stuff is not
much healthier than then even mcdonalds
according to a study at UCLA there's as
much sugar carbs sodium and overall
calories and like half the stuff on
their menu is this the worst thing that
could possibly happen to Americans even
subway even subway the one thing we were
told was healthy is also going to kill
us I think I think their tagline is eat
fresh right it doesn't say eat healthy
there there I think Americans like I
mentioned earlier we're a bunch of
dummies and so we automatically assume
that these are subs these I grew up in
Jersey and I mean a sub is not a healthy
thing right since when did it get
healthy and plus it's not even if these
are all prepackaged yeah when they bring
that meat out of the package you ever
see that and
yeah yeah they have a cheese steak on
the menu a cheesesteak there's no way
that could be healthy but yeah you could
go to McDonald's and get a salad if you
really want I don't know anybody that
does that why would you go to mcdonalds
to get a salad yeah and actually
McDonald's just dumped some of their
salad so probably a good idea nobody
goes to McDonalds first salaries out but
yeah it's a subway sandwich is basically
just it's a it's a hamburger in a longer
but yeah I just I'm shocked that
something that you can get at a gas
station is not good for you just shocked
yeah you never fill up your tank get a
footlong to go and feel like you're
doing something right well look I'm a
comic on the road and sometimes when
you're in you know scratcher but
Arkansas no offense Arkansas but that
sometimes your only option yeah you know
so yes of course I've had to have subway
but i never thought i was eating healthy
never not for a second i thought it was
the lesser of two evils I'd rather do
that than just you know fast food but I
was never fooled that something i could
get at inside they have them inside of
gas station literally into it and
they're always next to like a taco bell
and they share the same counter like no
one here is are we really being fooled
that this is healthy yeah it might be a
little healthier because look there's a
pickle but that that's about it that's
about it is there anything scarier than
that combo store what is it it's it's
subway what is it a Pizza Hut and Taco
Bell is that what it is those sadness
Ali yeah it really really is and
sometimes have to do it and you're in
jersey I whenever I'm in Jersey I always
find myself on those you know those rest
stops that are always confusing an
arrest
and and when you walk in it's just here
i am in in the depression court today
they call it a food court but it's the
saddest place it's joe sad it is and so
you just go any like I just have to eat
something but I'm not fooling myself
none of this is really nourishing my
body's just so don't die in Jersey
that's really basically it right so if
there was like an actual healthy version
of this and we see some of this stuff
popping up like an energy kitchen kind
of thing would it fly in America it
feels like it never really takes off
these like sort of healthier things they
appear and then they just kind of
disappear because Americans like our
salt that's exactly it so that is
exactly it you can you can say look this
is healthy but Americans like food to
taste a certain way and it has to have a
certain right of bad fats with that salt
and that sugar I mean there's sugar in a
lot of food that you don't think you
would never think there's sugar and why
but they need those preservatives or
something inside of us now in our tissue
almost like our DNA we're healthy food
does not taste good to the average
American it just doesn't do you have a
personal policy on this on how you go
about well I mean this report they
studied like a hundred twelve year olds
right i mean a coger odd isn't going to
go in there and say can I have the wheat
scooped out with just turkey and a
little bit of drug like know they're
gonna go for like the biggest baddest
sandwich on the menu yeah I think as you
get older you know as things start to
drop a little bit on your body as the
metabolism starts to slow down you make
healthier choices but you know 12 year
olds not gonna walk in there and ask for
the you know grilled chicken on it on a
on a wheat bun yeah you're a guy though
right I try to I try to run a nice shiny
coat oh that's all see you saw the
makeup your beard is all shiny do you do
have a nice shiny nice shiny coat right
and speaking of healthy choices I've
enjoyed having you guys on the show and
I'm gonna let you guys pimp yourselves
out because I feel comedians can always
do that more effectively than I can
possibly do that so you could talk to
camera three right there you got 10
seconds Kira go well don't go to my
facebook page cuz already told you where
I think about those people so Twitter
at kira comedy and website is kira
comedy calm and check out the mother
funny show does he go I hosts a podcast
called decently funny so go to decently
funny calm it's a lot of fun I just had
Jason Biggs on my show enjoy that and on
Twitter at the nosey all right and i'm
dave rubin I'm hope you know where to
find me at this point at Rubin report on
twitter and click like and share and all
that good stuff and fight with us down
there we'll look at them and review them
and send them to Kyra for the KGB to
take care of the rest of it okay thanks
guys we'll do it again next week